BUT WE ONLY HAVE ONE.
STAY WITH US.
WE START TONIGHT WITH BREAKING
NEWS.
HOW SENATORS CHUCK GRASSLEY AND
LINDSEY GRAHAM HAVE RELEASED A
HEAVILY REDACTED BUT VERY
REVEALING COPY OF THEIR CRIMINAL
REFERRAL AGAINST CHRISTOPHER
STEEL.
THESE REVELATIONS ARE BEYOND
STUNNING AND CONTINUE TO PROVE
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WERE
WORKING TOGETHER TO TARGET THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HERE ARE THE FINDINGS FROM THIS
NEW MEMO.
THIS WAS JUST RELEASED TODAY HE
WOULD NOT THE OLD MEMO ON
FRIDAY.
WE'VE GOT TO KEEP UP-TO-DATE.
SENATORS GRASSLEY AND GRAHAM
WRITE THIS.
WHILE WORKING ON A SECOND
DOSSIER, CHRISTOPHER STEEL WAS
WORKING ON THE OBAMA STATE
DEPARTMENT AND CLINTON ALLIES.
ONE MEMORANDUM BY MR. STEELE NOT
PUBLISHED BY BUZZFEED, THE
REPORT ALLEGES REDACTED AS WELL
AS REDACTED, MR. STEELE'S
MEMORANDUM STATES THAT HIS
COMPANY RECEIVED THIS REPORT
FROM REDACTED, U.S. STATE
DEPARTMENT, AND THE REPORT WAS
THE SECOND IN THE SERIES, THE
REPORT WAS INFORMATION THAT CAME
FROM A FOREIGN SUB SOURCE WHO IS
IN TOUCH WITH A CONTACT OF
REDACTED, A FRIEND OF THE
CLINTONS WHO PASSED IT TO
FUNDED MR. STEELE'S WORK, BUT
THE CLINTON ASSOCIATES WORK FROM
TEMPORARILY FEEDING MR. 'S
ALLEGATIONS.
IT RAISES HUGE ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS ABOUT HIS CREDIBILITY.
LET ME SLOW DOWN HERE.
IN ADDITION TO HILLARY CLINTON
BUYING AND PAYING A BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR A 12 PLUS MILLION
DOLLAR PHONY, FAKE NEWS RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA DOSSIER TO INFLUENCE
THE ELECTION, IS THAT NOT BAD
ENOUGH, YOU HAVE CLINTON
ASSOCIATES AND THE OBAMA STATE
DEPARTMENT FUNNELING ALLEGATIONS
FOR A SECOND DOSSIER TO
CHRISTOPHER STEEL.
WATCH THE SECOND PART IN TERMS
ON THE FACE, THE DOSSIER APPEARS
THAT MR. STEELE GATHERED MUCH OF
HIS INFORMATION -- LET'S DO THIS
REALLY SLOW.
FROM RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT SOURCES
INSIDE OF RUSSIA, ACCORDING TO
THE LAW FIRM, MR. STEELE'S
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
AND THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THE SENATORS ARE SAYING THAT
STEELE WAS USING RUSSIAN SOURCES
TO HELP THEM SMEAR THEN
CANDIDATE AND LATER ON INCOMING
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
THE SECOND MEMO IS ALSO ACCUSING
CHRISTOPHER STEEL OF LYING
THEY WRITE, "THERE IS
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE SUGGESTING
THAT MR. STEELE MATERIALLY
MISLED THE FBI ABOUT A KEY
ASPECT OF HIS DOSSIER EFFORTS,
ONE WHICH BEARS IN HIS
CREDIBILITY."
AS IF WE DIDN'T KNOW.
THIS NEW MEMO OUT TONIGHT ALSO
DETAILS HOW CHRISTOPHER STEEL
WAS BRIEFING SEVERAL MAINSTREAM
MEDIA OUTLETS.
FAKE NEWS OUTLETS.
IN THE SUMMER IN 2016 ABOUT HIS
FIRST FAKE NEWS DOSSIER.
ACCORDING TO THE BRITISH COURT
RECORD, STEELE BRIEFED,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
"THE WASHINGTON POST," YAHOO
NEWS, THE NEW YORKER, AND THE
OLD FAKE NEWS NETWORK SEE AND
THEN AT THE END OF
SEPTEMBER 2016 ABOUT THE
SO STEELE WAS FEEDING THE
DESTROYED TRUMP MEDIA LIES
DIRECTLY TO RUSSIA.
WE ALSO KNOW FROM FUSION GPS
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE DNC
WERE AWARE THAT HIS COMPANY
WHETHER IT'S CONTACTING MEDIA
OUTLETS ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
THEY ARE ALL WORKING TOGETHER.
LET ME REPEAT.
TONIGHT RENOWNED USE OF A SECOND
-- WE'LL CALL IT A DOSSIER.
AS WE TOLD YOU ON FRIDAY, THIS
NEW INFORMATION, IT'S ONLY 15%.
ONLY THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
DEVON UNIONS, HE COULD RELEASE
MORE REPORTS, AS MANY AS FOUR.
WE WILL ASK HIM TONIGHT.
MEMO THAT'S OUT.
SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY,
THEY ARE ASKING THE FBI FOR AN
ALSO BRAND-NEW TONIGHT ON THE
TO RELEASE THE DEMOCRATS'
TONIGHT THAT CONGRESSMAN ADAM
SCHIFF, THE DEMOCRATIC RANKING
MEMBER OF THE -- SHE'S OUTRIGHT
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
THE WHAT'S IN THE COUNTER TO THE
NUNES MEMO.
SCHIFF APPEARS TO BE LEAKING
MOTIVATION, WAS THERE A
POLITICAL ACTOR INVOLVED?
A POLITICAL ACTOR WAS INVOLVED.
THAT'S PART OF THE MISLEADING
NATURE OF THESE BE 24
APPLICATION.
IN TERMS OF THE POLITICAL ACTOR,
THE MOST IMPORTANT INFORMATION
FOR THE COURT IS WHAT DID
CHRISTOPHER STEEL KNOW?
GLENN SIMPSON HAS TESTIFIED THAT
CHRISTOPHER SEALE WAS NOT TOLD
THE IDENTITY OF THE LAWYER, THE
PARTY BEHIND THE LAWYER.
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
INFORMATION AT ESTABLISHING
CUSTOMER STEALS BIAS.
>> Sean: ADAM, WAS THE COURT
TOLD THIS WAS BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR BY CLINTONS AND THE DNC?
THAT'S WHY SCHIFF IS SO WRONG IN
SO MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS.
SOURCES TELLING US CONTRARY TO
WHAT EVER FICTION SCHIFF IS
PEDDLING, THE FISA COURT WAS
LIED TO.
NEVER TOLD WHAT THE FBI WAS
GETTING AND RENEWING THIS WAR
AND TO SPY ON TRUMP CAMPAIGN
MEMBER CARTER PAGE.
SCHIFF'S CLAIM THAT THE DOSSIER
WAS POLITICALLY TAINTED, IT IS A
MINOR FOOTNOTE.
IT NEVER MENTION THAT HILLARY
AND HER CAMPAIGN AND THE DNC
PAID FOR IT.
A PRETTY IMPORTANT OMISSION,
DON'T YOU THINK?
WE CAN ALSO REPORT TONIGHT
ACCORDING TO OUR SOURCES WHO
HAVE SEEN THIS DEMOCRATIC MEMO
THAT NOTHING IN THE MEMO
ACTUALLY REFUTES ANY OF THE
FACTS THAT WERE PRESENTED IN THE
HOUSE G.O.P. INTEL MEMO, WHICH,
BY THE WAY, WE TOLD YOU ON
FRIDAY.
THE FBI SAID THERE'S NOTHING
FACTUALLY INACCURATE ABOUT IT.
TONIGHT.
THE FISA JUDGE WAS NEVER TOLD,
NEVER, THAT HILLARY CLINTON WAS
PAYING FOR THE PHONY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE LIES ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
FIRST, TRYING TO INFLUENCE A
ELECTION, THEN USING IT TO GET A
WARRANT TO SPY ON AN OPPOSITION
CANDIDATE.
THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO HAS NOW BEEN
DECLASSIFIED, AND SCHIFF'S GOING
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS BLASTING,
RIGHTLY SO, SCHIFF, ON TWITTER.
SAYING, "LITTLE ADAM SCHIFF
DESPERATE FOR OFFENSE IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST LIARS AND LEAKERS
RIGHT UP THERE WITH COMEY,
WARNER, BRENNAN, AND KLAPPER."
"ADAM LEADS ILLEGALLY -- I
DISAGREE
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SCHIFF IS AUDITIONING.
HE WANTS A JOB ON CONSPIRACY TV
MSNBC.
I DON'T LIKE THAT COMEY'S
ASSISTANT GOT HIRED BY FIXED
--
LEADING A MEDIA CAMPAIGN ALONG
ATTACK CONGRESSMAN DEVON NEWNESS
AND THE FOUR-PAGE MEMO.
THIS FIERCE OPPOSITION IS NOT
EFFORT TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND TO DAMAGE AND
DESTROY A NEWLY ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
AS OF TONIGHT, I CAN PROMISE YOU
THEY ARE ALL SCARED OUT OF THEIR
MINDS.
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO KNOW
REVELATIONS.
THIS FRIDAY, FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW McCABE TESTIFIED BEFORE
CONGRESS THAT WITHOUT THE
DOSSIER, THE FISA WARRANT TO SPY
ON CARTER PAGE WOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN APPROVED.
BY THE WAY, I HAVE SOURCES
CONFIRMING ITS TRUE TONIGHT.
THE FISA JUDGE WAS NEVER TOLD
THAT THE DOSSIER WAS BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR BY THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
AND THE DNC.
A HUGE COMMISSION, MR. SCHIFF.
THEY ARE ALL COMPLICIT IN THIS
BECAUSE THEY HAD DIFFERENT
POINTS AT
-- THIS YAHOO! NEWS ARTICLE
WRITTEN BY MICHAEL ISIKOFF TO
CORROBORATE THE FORMER DOMAIN
PHONY DOSSIER.
THE FBI NEVER CORROBORATED THE
INFORMATION FROM TWO DIFFERENT
SOURCES AND THEY PRESENTED IT TO
ALSO SUSPENDED AND TERMINATED AS
AN FBI SOURCE FOR LEAKING TO THE
DEMOTED DOJ OFFICIAL BRUISE
OR, MAINTAINED A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH STEELE.
WE KNOW THAT BRUCE ORR HAD AN
OFFICE FOR CODE DOORS DOWN FROM
GENERATE A
JOURNEY A GENERAL
-- SPECIFICALLY HIRED
TO BUILD THAT TRUMP DOSSIER.
SHE WAS KIND OF PAID BY THE
CLINTONS WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT
LOGICALLY.
AS "THE DAILY CALLER" POINTS
IN THE OBAMA STATE DEFERMENTS.
BRUCE OHR REVEALED THAT DURING
WAS, QUOTE, DESPERATE, DESPERATE
THAT DONALD TRUMP NOT GET
ELECTED, PASSIONATE NOT HIM
BEING PRESIDENT.
THE MEMO ALSO EXPOSES DURING THE
INITIAL APPLICATION FOR THE FISA
WARRANT, THE COUNTER INTEL
DIVISIONS AT THE CORROBORATION
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY KNEW THEY
HAD NOT VERIFIED THIS.
YOU HAVE AN UNVERIFIED CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
BROUGHT BEFORE A JUDGE, THEY DO
NOT TELL THE JUDGE IT'S BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR, THEY DON'T TELL
THE JUDGE IT WASN'T VERIFIED.
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
WE'VE ALSO FOUND OUT FROM
FUSION GPS FOUNDER GLENN
SIMPSON, HE NEVER BOTHERED TO
VERIFY THE DOCUMENT.
SO THE FBI LIED IN THAT SENSE TO
THE FISA COURT JUDGE.
THEY NEVER TOLD HIM THE TRUTH,
NEVER MENTIONED THE DOSSIER WAS
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY CLINTON
AND THE DNC.
THEY USED A DOSSIER FILLED WITH
RUSSIAN LIES, AS WE NOW KNOW IN
TODAY'S SECOND MEMO, AS A
JUSTIFICATION TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND ON AN
INCOMING PRESIDENT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THAT MEANS AMERICA'S POWERFUL
TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE WERE
UNLAWFULLY WEAPONIZE IN ONE OF
THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWERS IN
AND FISA LAWS WERE MANIPULATED
BY TOP RANKING OFFICIALS.
BY THE WAY, I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
WE LOVE ALL YOU FBI SPECIAL
AGENTS.
WE LOVE THE GUYS IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
THE RANK AND FILE.
THE LINE.
WE AREN'T TALKING ABOUT RANK AND
FILE.
WHICH TALKING ABOUT IS THE UPPER
ECHELON THAT WERE TRYING TO
UNDERMINE, FIRST A CANDIDATE,
THINK ABOUT THIS.
JAMES COMEY TESTIFIED UNDER
OATH.
THE DOSSIER WAS SALACIOUS AND
UNVERIFIED.
HE TOLD THAT TO THE INCOMING
APPLICATIONS THAT RELIED HEAVILY
ON THE DOSSIER EVEN BEFORE HE
WHY WOULD COMEY DO THAT?
COMEY NEEDS TO BE HAULED RIGHT
BACK BEFORE CONGRESS AND ANSWER
VERY IMPORTANT QUESTIONS WE PUT
ON THE SIDE OF YOUR SCREEN.
COMEY HAS BEEN MORE THAN HAPPY
TO TWEET OUT HIS FEELINGS EVERY
DAY.
HE'S WRITING A BOOK.
THERE WILL PROBABLY BE A TV
PUNDIT AT CNN OR MSNBC ANY DAY,
WILLING TO TALK.
MR. COMEY, JIM, WHY DON'T YOU GO
TO CONGRESS AND ANSWER THESE
THE ENTIRE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION, THEY SAY IT WAS
STARTED BECAUSE OF A DRUNKEN
CONVERSATION, FORMER TRUMP
ADVISOR -- I KNEW THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN FOR NEVER HEARD OF
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE NEVER
DIPLOMAT THERE THAT WAS IN MAY.
ACCORDING TO THE NARRATIVE TWO
MONTHS LATER WHEN DEMOCRATIC
EMAILS STARTED LEAKING,
AUSTRALIAN OFFICIALS THEN TOOK
THAT INFORMATION, PASSED IT ONTO
AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE AGENTS.
APPARENTLY THE THRESHOLD, TO
LAUNCH AN INVESTIGATION TO AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN THROUGH THE
FISA COURT, IS THAT LOW.
ALL YOU NEED IS FBI, ALL THEY